let's talk about barack obama he was the
two-term president before
the orange guy and you know he's been
somewhat
quiet over the years you know he chimed
in every now and again
uh during the trump presidency but
actually not too much and
in my opinion that's what a good
president should do george w bush
has been very quiet post-presidency you
know they've worked on things there were
remember
during some of the hurricanes we had
bill clinton they trotted him out with
george
w and and you know they can work on sort
of humanitarian things together but
personally i think it's pretty good when
a president basically says hey i did my
thing and now i'm going to sort of
back out or you could be a statesman in
like a bigger sense without getting lost
in the mire and muck
of politics and obama's actually been
pretty decent about it not great and
and it's he's come out a little bit more
lately anyway he just
did an interview and you need to take a
look at this because uh he's going to
blame
a lot of stuff on you're not going to
believe it the right wingers and the
media
of course you know that right-wing media
machine it's so ubiquitous and
everywhere
because there's no left-wing media
machine right most of culture isn't
left-wing pushing all this nonsense on
us
but then he really makes the point of
you know
it's those racist white people that
really have the problems but don't take
my words for it
barack obama i also think that there are
certain
right-wing media venues for example
that monetize and capitalize on stoking
the fear and resentment
of a white population that is witnessing
a changing america
and seeing demographic changes and and
do everything they can to give people a
sense that
uh their way of life is threatened and
that people are trying to take advantage
of them and we're seeing it
right now right where uh you would think
with all the public policy debates that
are taking place right now
that you know the republican party would
be
engaged in a significant debate about
how are we going to deal with the
economy and what are we going to do
about climate change and what are we
going to do about
lo and behold the single most important
issue to them apparently right now is
critical race theory
who knew that that was the threat to our
republic
man i got to tell you i i voted for
obama twice i
i don't regret things in life because i
think you learn things by past mistakes
but i would say it was a mistake
voting for that guy you can see the way
through
his very calm cool demeanor and the way
that i'm sort of right about everything
because of the way i talk about
everything
that underneath it is actually a very
dangerous person
because first off he's saying that it's
right wing media that monetizes these
things now
the idea of that is just so on its face
ridiculous
left-wing media is absolutely everywhere
pretty much controls everything and we
all know that the culture war that is
raging right now
is finally that a couple say right
leaning or conservative voices or
whatever you want to consider me
are pushing against the giant thing that
has been monetized
through corporations corporations love
black lives matter corporations love
pride month corporations love antifa and
all of
this gender nonsense and everything else
so the idea that it's right-wing media
monetizing on people's fears
is crazy it's actually left-wing media
doing it which we're going to get to in
the next story in just a second
left-wing media is monetizing on
everyone's fears of white supremacy
which doesn't even exist there are no
structures of white supremacy in the
united states there are no political
people show me someone in the united
states government who is a white
supremacist who literally wants
laws that are different for white people
these people don't exist these
so he's actually they're doing what they
do with everything which is a complete
180 lie you're taking what you
do which is racialize everything and
you're making it seem that it's the
scary right-wing white people that are
doing it
then he says well republicans should be
focused on the economy
or climate change not critical race
theory now why would barack obama
want to diminish the danger that is
critical race theory which in essence
is now the driving force behind the
democratic party
it's because he's obviously for it and
wants you
to take your eye off the ball and yes we
should all be against critical race
theory and it is not misguided on the
part of republicans or conservatives
to not want their children taught in
school that america is fundamentally
racist
that systemic racism is real that things
like being on time and hard work and
getting math questions
correct are our tools of white supremacy
uh you would want children to be taught
that their skin color doesn't matter as
opposed to is the thing that matters
most
so in some ways it is the most important
thing because it's the thing that's here
to destroy everything else critical race
theory is here to ultimately destroy the
economy right critical race theory
doesn't want an economy that runs on
capitalism and free markets
and and freedom of choice and all of
those things and human ingenuity it
wants
giant systems of socialism and marxism
these are obvious
things so to link these things together
i may think a lot of things about barack
obama but i don't think he's an idiot
it's fairly obvious why he wants
critical race theory
taught in school and it's and it's
pretty freaking dangerous
um so he's lying about what the media
does and he's lying about
actually what critical race theory is is
his point because otherwise
what is his point right is his point
that we should be teaching critical race
theory which if it is then then he's
been fully
unmasked as a marxist which that i guess
that would be news
right in a normal time it would be news
if the former president of the united
states
fully came out as a marxist or is he
he's trying to simply diminish it so
that it can keep squeaking its way
through
so i mean oh and also
white america voted for him he's talking
about white america
white america voted for you twice barry
yeah and nobody cared what your first
name sounded like or what your last name
sounded like
or nobody cared that your dad was from
kenya or any of those things i voted for
you twice
it had nothing to do i think with you
being black or anything else
right like i voted for you because i
thought you were better than the other
guys john mccain and mitt romney
in retrospect i think the country would
be a lot better off if either one of
them and romney's
i think romney's horrible now right
because romney's just a pet republican
well i can go on mse nbc and they'll pat
me on the head and give me a cookie
cookie like brian stelter yesterday um
well anyway i think you guys see my
point i mean his implication
is that america is fundamentally racist
and these racist people are losing
control
and it's like barry the racist people
voted for you
this this meme of white supremacy is so
spectacularly
wrong and dishonest